the fall that they they ordered there
was gnats in it so it wasn't how many it
was like covered whoa it was really bad
cover yeah
[Music]
so Colleen is allergic to Nick's ears I
am really it's a weird story she's just
doing that to hurt my feelings she looks
at it and vomits they're a little hurt
all right how does that how does that is
that from sparring and stuff it's from
uh just being bad at fighting that's
what it's from it's from aggressive
cuddling it's from grappling again here
but also too you have to have a certain
type of ear for it to like really flare
up why because people grab it no it's
just like rubbing like forearms it's on
the mat people are headlocking you I get
nugget a lot you know excessive ear
sucking from his wife oh I wish I wish
she won't even touch these it's a whole
mouthful yeah dude mouthful is a good
way to say it yeah so in less important
news uh you guys ever find [__] that's
in your food like when you buy food and
there's like a hair in it oh yeah all
the time you know what you do you pull
the hair out and you finish your meals
yeah exactly right
obviously it's gross but then you just
go all right wait the pen I pretend it's
my hair yeah yeah if it's if it's from a
restaurant I eat it yeah if I open
[__] Honey Bunches of Oats and
there's pubes in there I'm not gonna
fish yeah that's that's true if it's
curly or if it's like more than three
is the power I think you're picking one
out and you go oh and you go oh Dad
that's too much man
yeah but you're still accepting it yeah
dude I think I might be a little
sketched out by two one is like okay
you'll be sketched out but you might
continue the meal all right imagine at
the beginning of your meal you take like
six bites right and then you [__]
find two of them two back to back
that's hurtful yeah I feel that but what
happens if you find
pennies in your chicken nugget oh lucky
day that is lucky in the middle of it
like you bite it and you're like oh some
money so money that is a lucky day
though I'd rather find money than hair
pennies inside of a chicken is this one
of those stories where like the person
put it in them themselves and then they
try to soothe in a chicken nugget I mean
odd people do some crazy stuff like the
finger and the chili yeah what's the
finger in the chili the Wendy's story
yeah I hippie trying to make a buck it's
like stick it in there like I'm assuming
people do weird stuff wait a finger in
it like a [__] human finger human
finger and a chili It's like a tip of a
finger or something correct oh that's
totally different and then it was like
it was like her husband's or something
yeah it turned out to be like they
planted it wait Did they answer the
question of how she had her husband's
finger off of his hand okay we're not
gonna talk about it maybe maybe it was
loose already I'm talking about pennies
yeah it might have been loose it might
have been and they're like well you know
it's already loose let's make use of
this yeah the husband was in bad shape
he was just falling apart okay
okay well this Potato Head was was her
husband yeah yeah this happened out of
McDonald's in Ohio okay in Jefferson
County just Ohio relate to that there
was a family that was doing you know
their regular McDonald's run goes and
gets some chicken nuggets for their kids
so it's different right when it's for
your kids because then you [__]
actually care on a totally different
level that's true and uh this kid uh
opens up this [__] chicken nuggets
and there's pennies literally three
pennies inside of a nugget which means
that's jackpot local McDonald's also
said that it wasn't a local chain issue
it had to be a manufacturer's situation
yeah because it's in the Nuggets yeah
it's like fried inside it's like fried
they don't make chicken nuggets at
McDonald's they just fry it they just
heat it up yep interesting whoa what do
you do when you find pennies in there if
it I would get pissed if it's a child
because I know that children are so
stupid they would probably swallow it
yeah that's fair right but if it's an
adult it's like money you could pay the
bills you should be happy you got you
got a three second discount people
without chicken nuggets like without
chewing it though somebody out there has
got to do it
that's how I eat my chicken well I'm
sure somebody out there is definitely
putting the whole nugget in yeah yeah
I'm pretty bougie now when I was younger
I don't think I really gave a [__] about
too much like if I got a hot bowl of pho
and there was a fly in it I'm like oh
the the heat would just burn the
whatever but now like let's say if I'm
like now if like if I ordered something
it's because I wanted it so I'd be like
oh um can you put more ice in this or
like I'm way more bougie than I was
before yeah but if you got that same
Bowl right now and there was a fly in it
I still feel like you might be like ah
and you take the fly and you I I went to
a I went to a fun place but that's
because it's hot enough and I don't care
but even if it's like if I get a burger
and I'm like man that ain't enough
cheese I'll be like can you put more I
don't care about the hair but I want
more cheese on this one okay but you
found three pennies in Tyga's nuggets
what do you do
honestly if I was in a rush I'd like
just don't eat this one yeah and then
eat the rest and then let's get out of
here I went to a pho place one time with
my mom and the fall that they they
ordered there was gnats in it so it
wasn't how many it was like covered whoa
it was really bad cover yeah it was
covered in that stuff like the same
amount
but when you like black pepper yeah
because it's so small yeah yeah oh
they're just like protein yeah
we left oh just straight left yeah
like no we we let them know and then we
left
did you pay the bill no no way right
you're like dude look at this [__]
that's pretty wild though we didn't eat
it though so it's like oh it just came
out they go here you go yeah it's super
special oh dude that's kind of dumb on
their part that they can't even
it was crazy it was like a few years ago
I love that none of us would even
remotely think like lawsuit yeah are
they suing them I mean that I feel like
that's like the normal thing that people
usually think about right they're like
oh perfect like big like what people but
like what people just every people I
feel like everyone says Americans
Americans American people yeah I feel
like everyone says it but they don't
actually do nah dude
what the [__] that's it you're gonna
take it out and still eat it yeah yeah
that's how we get down I think I don't
know it depends on how busy I am and how
hungry I am because there'll be days
where I'm just like
man I haven't ate in this this many
hours I'm here the food's in front of my
face if I complain now they're gonna
take this back fix it that's another 30
minutes yeah I need to get the [__] out
of here I have come I'll eat around it
and I go [__] this place yeah and I
leave I've complained with a hair and a
pasta one time because the hair was
super long so it's so clearly not mine
yeah and it's like maybe there was just
a different feeling from when you like
pull like a small hair out and like put
away versus like you're pulling it and
it's like pulling out the pasta
and stuff is stuck to it you're like
damn and the waitress walks by and
you're like I'll send that back so if I
go to a nice Italian place because I'm
going there for a specific feeling I'm
trying to achieve
that's different yeah versus a bowl of
pho that I'm like this Grandma barely
came here yesterday for real I don't
want to ruin her life it's time and
place but then even when they do that
too it's like you give it to them and
you're like hey they like fix the food
but then they don't like necessarily
contacted like we count your diet coke
we're like oh my God thank you it's like
weird like that is [__] up that's
weird because they usually will be like
we'll bring one right out that's that's
the best customer service though you
know plus it doesn't even affect their
like pay so I don't know why it's like
yeah why don't they just swap it dingy
yeah it might be bad management that get
on their case for their like why did you
why did you like waste food and [__] and
then they're just like oh my God I don't
know man if you got a [__] hair cut
the whole thing and wouldn't you go back
standard chilling length of hair
wouldn't you go back to a restaurant
suit if you found a hair in your pasta
and they were very apologetic and they
were like oh my God they're sorry yeah
they take care of you they hook you up
weren't you aren't you gonna be more
likely to go back to that restaurant
than if they were like it's just it's
not even that big of a hair like if they
did that you'd be like I think anybody's
ever
come on it's [__] I can't wait for
that to happen I've never gotten comps
actually for the hair thing though
really yeah because I feel like maybe
with like a lot of people do it and I
feel like you gotta ask for it bro how
long how long was the hair and did it
look exactly like yours I don't know
because if I'm a waiter I'm looking at
the hair and I'm like looking at your
head just real quick just like like you
know [__] do comparison yeah and then
I'd be like okay that's [__] up
wouldn't you feel judged if a waiter was
like
what if they were like
[Laughter]
leave it there
got parmesan in here we've got treatment
they put it back on top oh no dude Joe's
coming in and the same exact pair it's
like that long it's black and none of my
[__] kitchen staff has long hair then
maybe yeah we wear hair nets but it's
like what kind of scene do you want to
make all kitchen stuff come out real
quick everybody everybody out we want to
apologize to this guy with the long hair
everyone's just straight bald though
there are garbage people out there
though that do plant [__] yeah yeah like
they'll be like look at this Cricket
it's like man look at this Cricket that
she doesn't even exist here in La like
that species isn't even from here you
know just green Interstate species in
order to right it's like you bought that
[__] on Amazon the candy Cricket yeah
like I said did they sue did they not
Sue they didn't this lady did not Sue
she just said though that she wanted to
make sure that there was a public report
about it so that they can Warn and take
care of all the children in the area
that might be thinking about getting
chicken nuggets because dude if your kid
is swallowing chicken nuggets whole you
gotta get a new kid they got a big mouth
for a kid I got you kid throw out the
kid not the kid bro that's a defect
that's what I mean McDonald's is also
one of those like [__] franchises
though that if like they [__] up one of
my meals in a horrid way I'm still gonna
eat McDonald's it doesn't matter they're
so good because the feeling of the
McDonald's satisfaction is so high that
if it gets [__] up the goal is to
achieve that yeah it's like trying to
come you're like I don't really give a
[__] what happened I need to come I
didn't I couldn't come today I need to
come tomorrow yeah yeah yeah
ha
[Music]